so my name is julia stoneman i am the
associate director of the graduate
writing lab at yale uh porvu center for
teaching and learning i also
administered the purview center public
communications certificate program
for graduate school of arts and sciences
students who compete in the three-minute
thesis competition so we're really
excited to offer this to those people
who are competing in the 3mt and to
anyone doing online presentations which
is literally everyone right now um i'll
also add before i do the introduction of
our wonderful speaker
and expert
that you know they were training us to
do interviews by skype you know seven
years ago this topic was always relevant
um and i think that you know online
workshops and presentations and
interviews are not going to go away so i
think that this is a great these are
great resources to put in your back
pocket whether you're doing the 3mt or
some kind of you know kind of
really awesome presentation of your
research or if you're doing more kind of
mundane job market things and
other conferences so
very special person with us today guy
ortoleva i'm going to make his
introductions and before i do please
make sure that your mic is muted and
that your picture is off and that way
your image will not appear in the
recording
um and then if you have any
for questions what we're going to do is
we're going to have like a 15-minute q a
at 1 o'clock or a little bit before so
if you if you have a question that you'd
like to ask a guy please chat it and i
will keep track of them okay so i will
call on your first name during the q a
session
so guy ortuleva on behalf of the yale
broadcast studio is going to help you
improve your presentations with a
toolkit of communication and technical
tips
guy and his team i'll say right now are
they're all at the forefront of all of
the
uh communications that happen at the
university so they're there front and
center for graduation for matriculation
for all the ceremony they capture it
they share so many things publicly um
and within the university so these are
the professionals the they're the
professionals you go to for really
quality work so i'm just really grateful
for guys time and the work that he's put
into this presentation uh to let you
know a little bit more about him guy has
worked in the broadcast studio for
several years and both records and does
video editing before that he worked on
many television shows like inside
edition and hard copy uh documentaries
commercials and corporate training
videos he has a jd but more importantly
he has 30 years of experience in
communicating with video
so i'm gonna
mute myself and give all of the
give the mic over to a guy as it were so
thank you so much and welcome everybody
hello thank you for attending um
just remember you put your questions in
the chat
and um
i did have quite a few years working in
television but for the past two years
at yale
since covid much of my time is looking
at zoom recordings from all around the
world and all the guest lecturers
and then editing them and trying to put
them on youtube and
wherever they're going to go
and i've seen a lot so hopefully today
i can show you how to improve your image
on zoom and then specifically we'll talk
about the 3mt
types of recordings
when asked
why the show 60 minutes was so
successful for so many years
executive producer don hewitt said
tell me a story
and that's pretty much it the success of
that show has been that every sunday
night they tell you a story
and that's what you're doing when you're
doing your 3mt or anytime you're really
doing a presentation on zoom
you have to have a beginning you have to
have a middle and an end
and
after
we've gotten
mtv
in the 80s everything happens a lot
faster and i think it's very important
for you to get the attention of your
audience in the first 15 seconds give
them a reason to really continue paying
attention to you
and then at the end you want to wrap it
up with some real impact
and
in the middle you're providing all the
content and again you want to hold
people's attention throughout you have
to be dynamic
i found what was helpful in
planning for any presentation that i do
that i have a one sentence objective can
i sum up what i want to take away to be
what i want people to leave with
in one sentence and then as i prepare my
material i hold it up to that one
sentence nice is this a need to know or
a nice to know
one of the things to keep in mind when
you're presenting on camera in an or if
you have slides or however you're
presenting it
people can assimilate
one thing or another they can't
assimilate your sound and a slide at the
same time the balance is going to tip
one way or the other so you've got
something really compelling to say
you don't want the slide to be
distracting and if the slide has the
information that you really need to be
showing well keep in mind that people
are going to be looking at the slide and
your voice is going to be kind of in the
background
and what people are seeing of you has to
be useful be careful of your background
material be careful of your clothing
we'll talk about clothing later
but
everything that's in the frame
has to be useful
and not detract from you
so framing lighting and audio is how you
successfully tell a story
and that's what we're going to cover
today
um
proper framing
really is for example i'm in a fairly
balanced view you can see me pretty well
i have a little bit of headroom um
background is totally
in the
fall and away you don't really notice it
the lighting's pretty good you can see
my eyes
the audio quality is pretty good
and people you can understand what i'm
saying
the framing the lighting and the audio
is really important everything else is
nice but if you fail any of those above
you're in trouble
and again we're going to discuss the
three-minute thesis-specific things a
little bit later on
this fellow jeff carlson kindly did a
number of images and
this is what i see with so many
different zoom meetings you have a
variety of different images
and the first one is that not enough
headroom
or the up the nose is the same thing
with opening your laptop or looking up
at you
but you're cutting the top of your head
off
you want to avoid looking up so much
you're seeing the ceiling and all that
other stuff
second image too much backlight
and that's where you have a window or a
bright light source behind you
as we'll talk about later the camera
averages the amount of light so if
you've got a lot of bright light behind
you
your face is going to be dark
or worse if you have like a window and
you start moving your head one way or
the camera will open up you know you get
that almost pulsating look if the camera
will open up the iris and then close it
down
quickly
a plain white background is not so great
it kind of looks like a mug shot which
you don't want to really do
and then when you have too much headroom
this is the other example i use with
julia there
too much headroom is not so good
you've all seen the movie alien and
you've probably seen lots of scary
movies
and when the music starts playing
and you just know something bad is going
to happen
an alien the monster comes down from
above
well the reason you know that is because
they've added a little extra room in the
direction of where the bad thing is
about to happen
so i've always said that when you have
too much headroom that's because there's
going to be a monster descending upon
you so be careful with extra headroom
a busy background
there's lots of kind of busy backgrounds
one of the ones that i see a lot of
are bookcases and what happens
you've got a busy background and after a
while your voice drones on and people
are really reading the spines of the the
titles and the books behind you they
want to see what you're reading they're
not listening to you anymore so when you
have a busy background keep in mind that
that is going to be distracting and
what's the main topic you you want to
avoid distracting people and of course
in the bottom right is the good balance
that we were looking for
before i go on to any kind of a zoom
meeting
any of them i open up my zoom
preferences and i take a look at what i
look like and make sure that i have my
background is is relatively nice make
sure my camera is on hd
and then i also go to the audio and make
sure that i've got a reasonably good
audio the green bar
when you do a test audio should go about
halfway to three quarters of the way to
the right
that's going to give you really really
pretty good sound
and i do this before any time i go on
and i encourage you to do the same thing
because you want to see what you look
like
and you want to also make sure that your
audio is good so do this before each
meeting
and what people will see
there's a rule of thumb in video editing
in any kind of thing with camera
but it's built into our dna
that the first thing that people will be
looking for when they look at a frame
are other people's eyes it's just
natural
the next thing they'll look for is
motion if there's anything motion in the
frame and then after they've satisfied
themselves with the eyes and an emotion
they're going to start looking around
for the brightest light
and then finally details but i'll go
back to the eyes
i remember years ago my son had a a
lizard a little chameleon cute little
thing
but anytime you walk by the room or
walked in the room or was anywhere now
around him
he looked you right in the eyes
all animals all creatures
all people will first look
into your eyes and that's important
because you got to make sure that your
eyes are well enough lit and that
they're large enough in the frame that
people are going to see them otherwise
they're going to be looking around
the next thing is also your body
language
people tend to
gesture
your hand out like that which is great
if you're dynamic enough speaker a lot
of times people will be going like this
and you'll be carrying people's
attention
but your body language has to be
useful
this
doesn't help
you're putting up a barrier but your
body language is an important part and
as well as how you look we'll cover
clothing later but it's your visual
presentation of what you look like on
camera that says a lot
also are you going to be in the frame
with the slide i know with the 3mt
you're using panopto so you're going to
be side alongside you're to the left
side of the of the slide
in zoom a lot of times if you've got
slides you're going to be in the upper
right hand corner
so you've got to anticipate how that
will look
the best thing is to have frame yourself
up with a close-up or what we call a
medium close-up not your entire body
because again the eyes which is what
people are going to be looking for you
want them to be seen
and then whatever slides you have well
they've got to be telling a story and
they should amplify what it is that
you're saying because remember it's your
spoken word and how you make your
presentation that really carries the day
the slide is just amplifying it or
reinforcing you
and speaking of slides you got to make
sure that any images or video clips or
anything you have have been cleared with
copyright
you can easily get stuff from wikimedia
commons and other places or you can ask
permission um
the
the best thing to do is get these things
clear because your video your
presentation may end up on youtube and
if it does
they'll pick it off if you're borrowing
somebody's material without without
permission
when you're speaking to an audience
you got to be on the same level i mean
you don't like it when you have to look
up at somebody and just opening your
laptop and starting to talk doesn't cut
it anymore you really have to put
yourself at the same level as the camera
you should be lit
twice as bright as your background
and that will create a separation from
your background so you're going to have
to probably use some kind of lights
either daylight coming in or maybe a
light on the table or something
and that light should be near the lens
so it's not casting big shadows but it's
not blinding you either
if you're lost in the framing in other
words if you've chosen to
show all of your body or most of it
rather than a medium close-up or a
close-up
it's going to take away from your story
i'm here to tell you
especially if they put you up in the
corner or along the side when you're
showing some slides
you're going to be lost in the frame
and audio
you got to do
the audio well enough so that people
really understand you
you can get headsets you can use your
earbuds or best of all use some kind of
a cardioid microphone something that's
directional the microphone should be
no more than two or three feet away i
always say an iphone sounds great as
long as you have it close enough
choosing a background can be as simple
as opening up your laptop
getting up your zoom image so you see
yourself and then walk around to
different places in your house
find a good background something that
has some nice soft light or available
light coming in so it's lighting your
face has a pleasing background but move
around find the best place
you might find two or three places
i know my wife unfortunately took the
best place she does telemedicine so i
found myself down in the basement doing
my zoom events
but find yourself with a good background
windows can
hurt you if you've got them behind you
and you want to avoid
large flat surfaces that will start
reflecting the sound
more of a cluttered room at least on the
side so we don't see it can help break
up some of that sound
two most common errors in camera work
the low angle shot
one of my colleagues is along here in
the upper left-hand corner image and you
see he's got
his eye line is above the camera and
this happens typically people open up
their laptop
bring themselves on a zoom meeting and
start talking so you're
kind of looking up their nose
and then
you've got too much headroom
and
so
the the head room you got to just tilt
the monitor down
um and of course the bottom right we
have an example of proper headroom
back to
framing
we do in television something called the
rule of sixes we divide an image up with
six lines
and six areas and
this
image of me
kind of shows the way you want to
balance yourself out in a frame if
you're looking straight forward
you have a little bit of headroom
not too much underneath
so that's this is what's called a medium
close up and that's probably your best
bet your eyes are going to be visible
enough
i have one of these
backgrounds because again i'm downstairs
and i don't want to show
what's behind me so i use one of these
virtual backgrounds but what i do is
throw it out of focus a little bit
so you know put it in photoshop soften
it up and that way it's not distracting
or at least
hopefully not distracting from the
speaker
now the alternative framing is as
mentioned if you've got slides
the person's going to be in the upper
right hand corner and it shows me i'm
probably
blocking julia
but if i'm looking at one side and i'm
looking over here i'm looking out of
frame so you want to be looking in the
direction of your slides
because if you're looking in the
direction of the sides if somebody's
looking at your eyes their eyes are
going to be led back into frame where
the slides are and paying attention to
the slides but if you're looking out of
frame
well what happens people look at your
eyes and they're lost they're not
looking anywhere so
keep in mind
when you're doing a long presentation
you may want to have a script there you
can put it in the upper side of your
upper upper part of your frame but just
make sure you put it in the proper side
so that you're not
inadvertently looking out of frame
remember the eyes are the key
people are going to look in your eyes
and again with you're in a small frame
in the upper right hand corner on a zoom
image
or even on the three mts when you're off
to the side
you're a smaller picture out of
necessity so you want to have that
medium close-up shot so that we can see
you
because your face is what's really
important
but avoid drawing attention away from
the subject matter which is you and or
your slides
and so how does a camera see
well it sees like we do
uh it has an iris
so in this image you know when you have
a little bright light you squint a
little bit
or your eyes will your iris will open up
to bring in more light and a camera is
pretty much the same only
it's not quite the same
it's not adjustable infinitely
it adjusts to the limit of its
technology
but it has something
called auto iris
it averages the amount of light
so
in a situation where you have bright
light behind you
the camera is going to average the
amount of light and it's going to close
its iris down because it thinks it's got
plenty of light but what happens is now
you're darker
and
when technology averages
it's not so good so for example
if your head is in an oven
and your feet are in the freezer a
computer might say hmm on average that
person is quite comfortable
so averaging in technology isn't always
your best friend
and it also happens
when you have
color
and one of the questions that people
will ask me sometimes when they've seen
themselves on a zoom is why am i orange
why am i orange
well it happens because the camera is
averaging
not just the
amount of light but it's looking at the
kind of light or the color of light so
in other words if you have daylight or
in the surface a lot of white walls with
having daylight reflecting off of it the
camera thinks that well this is more
outside so it's going to adjust itself
to one end of the color spectrum and if
you have an incandescent light on on
your desk
your face is going to be orange
quick
simple solution for this is to buy some
daylight bulbs to put in your lamp
and
what about this color difference
if you remember the old
electromagnetic spectrum from back in
your science class days
the visible spectrum is from the low end
which is the reds
all the way up to your blues
so a candle light is at the one on the
low end of the spectrum it's very warm
your incandescent bulbs that most people
have in their houses
are in the low end of the spectrum
we measure color temperature in kelvins
or k we call it
so for example your typical
bulb that you have in your house your
soft white bulb is around 2600 kelvin
2600 k we call it
daylight on the other hand
uh is probably around 56 k
and a screaming blue sky could be
maybe 10 000 k so it's way up in the
blue end of the spectrum
so if let's say you have a situation
where
you've got some nice soft daylight
coming in
but you also have a lamp on your
helping to eliminate your illuminate
your face
you want to make sure that the two color
temperatures are not fighting one
another so if the camera looks at
the light
and averages it
and it says gee we're at the blue end of
the spectrum and you put some orange
light on your face you're going to look
orange your background's going to look
fine so again that's where the daylight
bulb as an option for your light
fixtures will come in
and the other opposite end
happens too
there have been a few times that i turn
on my camera and i'm blue
why because
i over compensated
and i had a blue shirt on
so
sometimes
you know it will the cameras will pick
up on your clothing too
and say oh gee we're outdoors
so again take a look at yourself but the
typical situation that comes in that
becomes a problem is when the camera
sees a lot of daylight
adjust for one end of the spectrum the
blue end and then you have an
incandescent bulb
and now you look a little orange so you
want to compensate that with the
daylight bulb
natural light versus artificial light
if in the upper left-hand corner
wouldn't it be nice that all our zoom
meetings can have nice soft light coming
in
through big windows that person looks
great
but we don't all have that luxury
so the person in the lower left has nice
daylight coming in you see the coming in
and it's illuminating her face in other
words it's in front of her not behind
her
we don't actually really know what's
behind her but humor may hear you have a
lot of daylight coming soft daylight
illuminating your face
but then she also has a lamp on her desk
to help illuminate herself a little bit
more and that would be a classic
situation where you put a daylight bulb
in it
now
people have decided that they need more
light
when they do all their zoom eating so
enter the ring light
a lot of people go out and buy these
ring lights and they're okay
unless you put it right dead above the
lens of your camera and then if you see
the jeff carlson image in the upper
right hand corner you start seeing
reflection of the ring light in your
glasses
or in your eyes you'll see like a little
circle of light
the best thing to do is to put your
light off to the side my rule of thumb
in lighting any situation is that i
always take the light and move it one
foot over and one foot above the lens
that's typically my starting point in
any kind of a lighting situation
so if you're going to have any extra
lights that would probably be a good
place to start and then you fine tune it
a little bit as you go along
what we will hear
audio is really important in
any kind of a online presentation or any
kind of a recording
people will kind of forgive
not so good images
but if they don't understand the audio
you lost them they're gone
so your audio has to be
good quality it has to be clear
the microphone
you should have a directional microphone
if you can or earbuds or a headset
or if you're going to use your laptop
microphone you got to have it closer you
can't have it any more than two to three
feet away
so always remember you have picture and
sound
um
an iphone some people when they're doing
their recordings will use their iphone
just make sure it's no more than arm's
length away from you
set it up on a bookcase or on a tripod
or something like that so it's at eye
level
and
make sure it's close enough
now zoom does have those controls
for
improving your sound
i found that a usb microphone
if you can find them actually now
they're not hard to find when the covet
first happened it was difficult to find
one of these usb microphones
but let's go through a little bit of a
dive a little deeper into audio
the sound waves from your voice or any
kind of sound
hit the diaphragm inside the microphone
it vibrates and that creates an
electrical signal
the closer you are to the microphone
the better unless you're too close and
then you'll distort it
most microphones have different pickup
patterns so you have to be aware of that
in the bottom picture
you have the the microphone on the left
is what we call an omnidirectional
microphone it hears equally in all
directions
whereas the second one that's a cardioid
it's a heart-shaped pattern and that
picks up more directionally which is
actually your best in this situation
then you have other patterns
especially in the one in the bottom
right
in the blue window there that's a figure
eight pattern so that's wonderful for um
podcasts when you have one microphone
for two people on it on either side
now the
picture on the the right
gives you kind of an idea of what we
call the fall off
or the the db or
decibel pattern
you'll see that right at the surface of
the microphone
you got 25 db
but it doesn't take much for it to fall
off to like 5 db so you have a
significant loss in audio quality
by not being close enough to the
microphone
so
the
the way this manifests itself is that if
you have a microphone far away it's
picking up more of the room noise
and you're going to sound
echoey
and it's not going to be that clear and
distinct
um this is a closer shot of my
microphone i use a yeti microphone here
and you'll see that it does have a gain
control on it but more importantly has
that little pickup pattern that's the
the
center image there
you want to make sure it's on that
cardioid or heart-shaped pattern
i know so many people get themselves a
microphone and then forget to set it
where it needs to be
and then you always go on to your zoom
preferences
and you do your test audio and play
around with it
so before you do your all-important
recording or meeting
test the microphone make sure that you
don't have the mute button pushed on it
which i've done more than once
and
see if you can get a good clean sound
where the green bar goes about
two-thirds about two-thirds to
three-quarters of the way
to the right
distance between me and the microphone
and you get a good sound and now you're
ready for your important meeting because
people really really understand you
so some audio tips
pay attention to your environment
and do this when you're selecting a
location to do your recording
so not only is it a good background but
stop and be quiet for a moment and
listen
are you hearing some noises that you can
either turn off
or you can avoid
everything from the refrigerator that
might come on to um
i i know some rooms you you hear the the
pipes or you hear
just the sound of the the air air
handlers so avoid situations like that
yeah it is obvious but silence your
phone and your emails and all that other
stuff because they will go off right in
the middle of your best recording
wrestling of papers tapping on the table
i've got my little
clicker over here
you don't want to have it tapping on
surfaces or setting down but wrestling
papers especially if you're reading from
a script that can really be picked up
very quickly and easily
also consider your surfaces
sound waves bounce
so in other words if you have a lot of
large flat surfaces
the sound waves will bounce off of that
and come back into the microphone
and especially consider behind you if
you have a big flat wall behind you
guess what happens your voice goes out
it gets picked up on the microphone
bounces off of surfaces and comes back
into the microphone that's what gives
you that echoey
muddy sound
so always pay attention to flat surfaces
break it up you know a couple chairs
here and there
curtains
but also pay attention to what's behind
you um i know that that
believe it or not i was working in this
industry for many years and we used to
make these
little um sound booths
and you put foam on it and you could
actually buy them but you used to be
able to do voice overs
and i remember talking to some real rock
and roll expert who had done so many
recordings with bands and stuff like
that and i was saying yeah you know
we got this nice
foam stuff
and it was okay but for some reason the
sound still isn't great he said guy
what's behind you
this is uh the wall
you idiot the bounce little sound is
bouncing off the wall
oh sorry so after that we always put
some curtains or something behind so you
know it's not intuitive it's behind you
but those large flat surfaces behind you
can actually be muddying your sound
because the sound waves are bouncing off
and hitting the microphone a little bit
after your voice did
clothing choices um
white
black
can
[Music]
certainly black can be very slimming
but
remember what we're trying to do we're
trying to show off your face
if you have a black shirt on
and
the camera is saying oh gee i don't have
enough light let me open up the iris
because it's all very dark
well now your face is going to be too
bright
so you have to pay attention to your
clothing first of all as do you know it
has to be pleasant and something that
you want to wear
but you also want to make sure it's not
giving you some technical problems
if you have a lot of white
or black it can sometimes trick the
camera's iris into doing things that you
didn't really want it to do
so we often recommend people use kind of
neutral clothings pastels off-whites
grays browns
and blues
that usually works best and certainly
easier for us when we're lighting people
but it'll be easier for you to adjust
the camera which will automatically be
adjusting
greens are good
unless you're doing chroma key because
most of the chroma keys are green
screens
television computers really don't do
reds very well oranges
or pinks
they get confused they don't really
really know how to distinguish them that
well you can wear them
but just keep in mind that it is going
to be a little bit more of a challenge
for the camera
avoid
pinstripes real thin pinstripes or
herringbone any kind of a close pattern
and the reason for that is that the way
the image is being created
the it's scanning back and forth their
electrons are scanning back and forth
and that's how
television video whatever is able to
create an image and in that scanning
back and forth
thin
patterns
confuse the camera
and so you'll have a what we call a
moire pattern if you have a very thin
pinstriper or herringbone it'll look
like worms are crawling up your shirt
which is not good
avoid high contrast
you don't want to be mixing black and
white
because again
you're thinking for the camera and
that's terrible thing is we're dealing
with technology here and we have to
think for it
uh you have to anticipate how it's going
to react
jewelry yeah that can be an issue
but you know
you you want to dress the way you feel
comfortable
uh just take a look at it
and that's kind of the rule of thumb a
lot of this make sure you look at
yourself before you do the recording and
see if you can make an improvement here
and there
but the bottom line is
it's
setting you up to look good and make it
visible your eyes visible you want to be
able to see
the person because you're the one that's
the subject matter and it's your
presentation what you're saying and how
you look that's really selling your
story
powerpoint slides uh you're going to
have them um
and again i i understand with the 3mt
you're going to be
alongside of your powerpoint
in most of us the zoom puts us in the
upper hand corner upper right hand
corner
but you want to make sure that you're
using widescreen
you want to make sure that your slides
are supporting
your story not restrain replacing it or
distracting people
uh 1920x10a you got to remember this
number 1920 by 1080 which is widescreen
it's the old 16x9 about
10 15 years ago everything went
widescreen
so the old 4x3 kind of squarish image
that we used to watch on television
that's kind of gone unfortunately
powerpoint still has that as a default
so you want to make sure that when
you're creating your slides you select
widescreen
and it gives you more workable area too
i find that it's better to use a dark
background with white or light text
again i'm adverse to having bright white
sources
or light sources that are distracting
because
and the rule of thumb when people are
looking at any given frame they're going
to look at eyes first then they're going
to look for motion and then they're
going to look for the brightest spot
so if your slide is very bright and
white
it's only natural but it's going to be a
little bit a little distracting
visibility resolution you want to just
think about
how people are seeing your image are
they going to be looking at it on a cell
phone or an ipad
sure everything looks great at arm's
length with a laptop or a computer but
what will that slide look like when it's
reduced to a smaller image
and again remember your copyright
do proper attribution you want to not be
surprised down the road that you
borrowed something that you shouldn't
and in this world if everything online
still lives there
people can find it and they'll be not
happy if you just go ahead and use their
stuff without asking
and just to help illustrate the
powerpoint
not every presentation you do will
always be seen at arm's length it may be
on a screen
in a room in a conference room and so
think about
how
people in the back of the room are going
to be seeing it if you have a lot of
white on your slide
it's going to be difficult for you know
i'm here i'm talking about how the
camera would adjust for but also for
people
if you have a lot of white your eyes are
like adjusting for
the room and the people and now the
images are kind of blown out
whereas if you kind of adjust to your
camera
to see
a slide that has a lot of white
everything else is going to be a little
darker
so again this is another plug for
putting darker slides darker background
slides with light text
and
only natural a lot of logos and other
images that you have are on white so you
can crop them and then drop them in as
appropriate
this isn't a another way just your use
your photoshop or any of your software
to just crop it
so now let's talk about the 3mt uh three
minute thesis
since you have a very short amount of
time to tell your story obviously you
have to decide what is the need to know
from the nice to know
uh this is where making that objective
what do you want people to really walk
away with at the end of your three
minutes
so
your visuals are going to amplify your
story but keep in mind that if you've
got a complicated slide or you re tell
people to look at the slide you're not
going to be hearing your voice quite as
much
again we assimilate
a picture or sound not both equally
uh if you're going to be in the frame
with the slides
and anticipate it and again in this
situation you're going to be to the left
you're going to be alone the side of the
the image
i find that it's better to
initiate you make your your first
contact remember your first 15 seconds
you're drawing people in
talk a little bit refer to the slide and
then back to you
so that people know when they're they
should look at the slide instead of
being distracted and then come back to
you
and make sure that your your important
points are being heard with their full
attention and not kind of a distracted
attention where they're looking at the
slides and looking at you and
what do they really want to concentrate
on
obviously if you can trim out some
portions that are not needed but most
importantly you want to be dynamic you
want to bring that story to life
and give yourself time so that you're
not rushing it
maybe it should be a two and a half
minute thesis planned to fill in for
three minutes
so here's a few examples
if you notice the framing
the way you're going to be recording
these is on panopto so that's going to
put you along the side
and unfortunately it's going to leave a
lot of dead space in the top and bottom
which is all the more reason why you
want to make sure that your slide is not
too cluttered
in this situation it was very dynamic
speaker he framed himself such that you
could see his hands
and that's okay if you're going to be
dynamic
the background's a little plain uh it's
not bad but when you have a background
that that's
that's that simple you got to make sure
you have enough light on your face
because you're going to have reflected
light too
but this fellow
had broken slides into logical patterns
so he talked he referred to the first
part of his slide then back to him and
then to the middle and then to the
latter part so he kind of broke his
slides up into a logical fashion and
then his presentation referred to it and
then back it was very successful
this person did a very similar type
thing you notice that her framing is
much closer much easier to see her eyes
she wasn't one that was gesturing that
much
but her slides also were very logically
laid out
it was easy for the eye to follow those
things and then come back to her and not
be stuck on the slide trying to figure
it out
um
it was uncluttered which was really nice
um
this image okay i'm going to kind of
toss it to you
what do you think about this
right
his camera level is a little low and so
we're ceiling seeing a ceiling
the background is a little cluttered but
not bad i don't think this one really is
that bad but i think the most important
thing is to get the camera at eye level
you want to do that and then
you know he still would have been fairly
well lit but seeing the light
fixture up above him is going to confuse
the camera so i think if he had gotten
himself at eye level
everything else kind of would have taken
care of itself
but it also gives you is this a
situation where you would want to use
one of those virtual backgrounds or the
soft focus ones
i think those are fine
it keeps you from being distracted by
the background
the only thing that you have to
keep in mind in using the virtual
backgrounds
is to make sure it's a clean what we
call a clean mask in other words you
don't see any residual image as the
person you move your head and you've
probably seen if you use the virtual
background when you move a little bit
sometimes the camera
the technology doesn't continue making a
nice clean
image around you it's kind of like soft
and sometimes you'll actually see a
little bit of the background
so try things out in a circumstance like
this you could argue that
aside from getting at eye level you
could argue that maybe the background is
a little too busy and you want to go
with a soft focus virtual background
or you could just go with what it is
his slides again
you're actually looking at the eyes of
the zebra for a second there too
so you know make sure your slides are
easily visible you're not wasting any
space because in a situation like this
you're going to be
your slide
is only about one third of the usable
entire
screen
so you know playing accordingly
uh going back to images and legal issues
and stuff like that um
since i do have a jd i have to think
about these things
you want to be careful of your copyright
and make sure you get permissions and
all that stuff and the old saying if you
do it right you can sleep at night
when i upload
videos to the yale youtube channel i am
continuously amazed
that within a minute
sometimes seconds
i will know whether there was a legal
issue and there's a copyright issue
usually with music
you know sometimes i'll get the material
and we edit it and we put it up and you
don't realize that the presenter had
something in it
but on
youtube and any of these online things
they were able to pick up misused images
and certainly misuse sound
so you want to be careful and it's as
simple as sending an email to the person
that you're using their images and just
ask permission
speaker permission forms
the rule of thumb is that if you're
using somebody's name and likeness they
need to give permission
so you may have been asked to sign a
release form for your three mts or any
other time that you're using a guest
speaker
alternatively
in some cases you can put a notice at
the beginning that says the event is
being recorded and it gives you an
option out
uh or when you option in you know that
you're being recorded and it may be
become public
and yes your presentation may be seen on
youtube all of you if that's one of the
places that
material that we do
goes
the yale office of general counsel has a
website
they do have some legal information and
some guidance
and they have something called a fair
use tool
if you have questions about whether what
you're using is
you know fulfills the exclusion from
copyright for what's called fair use
they have a tool and you could just look
at it
basically fair use is a four-point
balancing test
where you're looking at different
elements of the image and balancing it
to see whether it tips the balance to
yeah that's fair use go ahead and use it
to
that's not really fair use you're
probably going to get in trouble
so that's one thing to consider
so
bottom line you're going to successfully
communicate your story on this right
when you're online you're telling a
story keep in mind that people can
assimilate the spoken word
or your images but not necessarily at
the same time certainly not equally at
the same time
the
video resolution
is important
many people do look at things on
cell phones or ipads
just keep in mind i i
i told you to remember the 1920 by 1080
that's your full rev resolution for high
definition
it may be squeezed down to 1280 by 720
and it's still your
by nine aspect ratio but if things get
squeezed down
is your slide going to be so detailed
that
we don't see it or it's going to be so
detailed that people are spending their
time trying to figure it out and they're
not paying attention to you so again
that's a plug for making sure that your
slides are
not cluttered
and remember about the slides is they
should be supporting your important
spoken points
your spoken word is going to carry the
day that's going to decide whether you
are successful in communicating your
story or not the slides will help
but it's your spoken word that's going
to make the difference
and if you're on a slide
your voice is reinforcing the visuals in
other words if you've called people's
attention to the slide and you want them
to be looking at it keep in mind that
they're going to now be focused on that
and they're going to be reading it and
your voice is not so important so that's
not the time when you put your make your
most important point you want to get
people back to you
and then you can make your your your
point
but above all
you're telling a story
with your voice
and your visuals
so
hopefully that helped you get
your online presentation in your staging
in order and don't forget the evaluation
form
and so we can stop the screen sharing
and maybe we can get on to some of these
questions
thank you so much guys so virtual hand
claps i'm sure uh
from everybody
and i had i was tracking some excellent
questions so i think i'll just throw
them your way i'll keep my camera off
you know and
um does that sound like a good
good one
sure so before we move on to the first
question um can people reach out to you
guys if they have questions about their
own presentations or logistical
questions is that all right yes yes okay
i know you're very responsive on emails
as well
wonderful okay so my first question is
from linda uh this is a bit earlier in
the presentation linda wrote my zoom
puts the speaker directly to the right
of the slides centered on the vertical
axis
is that a setting that's fine yeah that
is a setting um there is a side-by-side
view or the upper upper view
um
i think in the recording it will always
put it in the upper right hand corner
but in the actual what you see at the
time you're doing it uh it's along the
side
i frankly prefer it along the side if
you ask me
because when it's in the upper right
hand corner it sometimes obscures part
of your uh powerpoint
carson asks would you recommend that we
either use an image background or a
blurred background my only real-life
background options are white walls or
bookshelves
um
you can try with the
uh
image
again one suggestion is to try and and
soften it so it's not so sharp like for
example i had behind me a picture i took
when we were out hiking
and i looked at i said well that looks
really really nice um but it's too nice
it's going to be distracting so i did
made it soft focus
a little bit so it's not as prominent
i kind of like the soft focus background
on these virtual backgrounds
uh
as long as it's not
seeing a bright light behind you
that can be a pretty good choice
or again if you've got an image that
you're comfortable with and it's not
distracting and i think that's kind of
the guiding principle there uh is it
distracting and drawing the attention
away from
uh the viewer
that you don't want to do yeah and
carson's right there with his image so
maybe he can look at it right now it's
just slightly blurred but actually in
the in the six paint panel
example that you were giving about like
good and bad ways to to kind of
put yourself in front of the lens there
is a bookshelf and the good one and the
good image right with the warmer walls
but it's not as busy of a bookshelf it's
not an industry it's out of focus it's
out of focus and i think that's the key
thing uh it's far enough back that you
can't really pick out
individual images because
believe it or not people get bored and
they start looking around in an image
for something else to look at and if you
give it to them they'll look at it
so i think in that uh image where jeff
carlson uh
if you recall the the bookcase in the
background was a little softer and out
of focus
interesting so as long as they can't
read the spine
then you're fine
yeah i think so and just
look at it yourself are you distracted
by it is there something in there that's
really drawing your eye away from it
well then it's not so good find another
background
okay thank you so much asks would you
suggest any simple post processing steps
for the 3mt videos
um
in the past we actually used to edit
those we did them you know when we were
recording them in a
auditorium right now
i don't know what to say on that uh
you're being
being recorded on panopto i don't know
whether what options you may have
on that i i just don't know
that that would probably be the question
for the administrator for the 3mt as to
whether other options you have from
working with panopto in the past because
we've you know uploaded
fellowship panels and you know things
like that you can it's very easy to use
the
clip you know clip the vid you can clip
it very easily it's right there it's
like little scissors like literally
there
so what you could do is player i would
suggest playing around first record some
willy-nilly thing that doesn't matter
upload it and then see what features you
you'd like to have you know in that way
it'll give you some
um
abilities to if you wanted to clip or
yeah and i think along that same line um
that might be a good time for you to try
out your slide uh is this something that
is cluttered and difficult to read
when it's now on the smaller screen
uh so that might be a good way if you
can do a test recording uh with your
slide and then look at it after look at
your recording afterwards can you
clearly see the slide
and you
or not
and then make adjustments accordingly
melissa asks will other mobile phones
work for sound or just iphone
well as a proud owner of an iphone um i
don't know
i'm assuming so i mean i gotta believe
that uh you know
other iphones have microphones on them
uh so it should
you do a test recording i mean try it
just remember it's the proximity to the
microphone that makes a huge difference
if the camera on your phone and the
microphone
is more than arm's length i think you're
going to start having some fall off
but i i would just try it
so then linda asked a question about
copyright
in their experience live academic
conferences like classroom teaching have
different copyright terms but it sounds
like since this is being recorded is it
just a given that it will be
treated like a public recording or
specifically for 3mt and then in
brackets i mean does this more strict
sense of fair use copyright apply to all
recordings
for yale purposes or specifically to
this competition
that's a good question i do recall that
the three mts do end up on youtube
i think i recall that
um
i think it's a good
practice period
uh you know just borrowing stuff because
it's available is not a good way to live
your life
and
the classroom exclusion is kind of
narrow so in other words i think if you
were to go to go to the office of
general counsel and take a look at their
fair use uh analysis tool
uh
you'll see that you know there's there's
a narrow band there on what is
still considered
fair use in classroom
um so you know without giving any legal
advice i think the bottom line is
try and get permission to these things
or
certainly put the attribution at the
bottom so in other words it doesn't take
too much
when you're putting together your slide
to put an attribution of where you got
it from
at the bottom and you know it's small
text
well those are the only questions that i
got in the chat so i don't i'd like to
leave open some room for if anyone else
wants to ask a question live you can
um
raise your hand and kind of mute
yourself and just throw it out there
um while people are thinking
uh guy are you also is it something that
would be appropriate to maybe ask for
like schedule a meeting with you if
you're a 3mt
contestant to kind of work the slides
kind of give you get your feedback um or
are you to you know what are the
parameters do you think for something
like that
send me an email
okay
there is guy.orderliva
yale.edu
uh send me an email and we'll see what
we can do i'm i'm sure that people are
not gonna be breaking down my doors
so i'm sure we can find some time to
help you
that's great i mean yeah it's really
just about
what you're willing to put into it but
just from working with guy clearly he's
very knowledgeable so if that's a
resource that you have time to consider
i would highly suggest that and it
counts for the certificate program too
as a consultation so
um oh boy yeah well guy thank you so
much this was as always this is amazing
super helpful i wish i had known this a
long time ago but this is why we do the
work that we do to bring these resources
to all of you so you can you know go off
and conquer uh and do amazing work that
you do and share it with the world uh so
uh thank you so much guy more to come
i'm sure this was really wonderful and
thank you everyone for participating and
attending and let's give like a virtual
round of applause